TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
Play Time is our annual global
event series for Google Play,
and it kicked off last week
with some exciting updates
to the platform.
Take a look at the post
to learn about updates
to app bundles, the Instant
Apps size limit increase,
reducing crash
rates and improving
quality, and much more.
Spinnaker now includes a
new Kubernetes provider
that allows you
to take advantage
of the full flexibility
of Kubernetes
while abstracting away much
of the complexity of managing
manifests.
It also integrates with
the Helm package manager
to template your manifests,
and includes initial support
for traffic shaping
via [INAUDIBLE]..
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
Compose Actions
and Gmail add-ons
make it easy for you to add
attachments, reference records,
or liven up your
messages with content
from your favorite
third-party apps right
as you draft your
message in Gmail.
And they're now
generally available.
Head on over to the post
for some examples and a link
to the developer documentation.
The Go 1.11 runtime is now
available in beta in the App
Engine standard environment.
For all the details and a
video to help you get started,
head on over to the post.
OK, so this isn't a
new API or anything,
but I thought it was
just too cool to pass up.
The Google Cloud team recently
partnered with NASA's Frontier
Development Labs 2018
Astrobiology Mission
to simulate and classify
the possible atmospheres
of exoplanets and the
search for signs of life.
For more on what that
means, what the teams did,
and what's next, take a
look at the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
SPEAKER 1: There's a
dog in the background.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Were
you able to see him?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
I could see his shadow.